hello everyone and yes i am showing the
game today instead of yesterday it is
the armageddon game between magnus
crossing and maxime vashiela grav they
repeated the groomfield from the
classical section but maxine found an
improvement on their classical game and
the game took a new turn it's a very
interesting one so you guys will enjoy
it it's super complicated and
unfortunately uh armageddon is just not
enough time for uh positions that arise
in this game uh so magnus has the white
pieces and if you haven't seen it do
check out the classical game so you
would understand the
completely new game part uh a little bit
better so here we have d4 by magnus
knight to f6 uh sorry about that
uh we have c4 everything the same as in
the classical game g6 going for the
king's indian defense knight c3 d5
captures captures uh and again e4
captures captures and magnus goes uh
sorry after bishop to g7 magnus goes for
this uh like we mentioned in the
previous video fourth most popular line
bishop to b5 check we have c6
magnus um has to retreat with the bishop
and maxine gets all this expansion on
the queen side knight of three castles
and now uh magnus also castles we have
a4 bishop to c2 and c5 so everything the
same as in the classical game rook to b1
and here in the classical uh section a
maxim continued with bishop to g4
however after the game uh of course both
of them most likely check the engine to
prepare something special if the
positions repeat
and he plays knight to c6 now the engine
only slightly prefers knight to c6 over
bishop to g4 but it is enough for maxine
to create a completely new game and this
is where we take a new turn uh the game
is now completely different uh
from the the classical game which of
course makes sense as we have a
completely new game so here magnus has
to decide whether to play d5 or e5 and
it's that's always an unpleasant choice
when facing the groomfield if you don't
know it by heart then you will just push
a pawn and here we have e5 uh it's okay
to push both of the pawns depending on
what kind of a game you want to have so
here we have e5 rook to b8 and now
bishop to e4
going after the knight here uh similar
like he did in the classical section
with bishop to f5 now attacking the
bishop and of course if you capture the
knight then you blundered the rook on b1
so bishop captures allowing um the
doubling of the f pawn but as you'll see
the position will be quite solid so g
captures an f5 queen to d3 going after
the pawn and now queen to d7 defending
we have rooked a d1 putting a rook on
the uh maybe uh soon to be opened the d
file and rook f2 d8 maxim does the same
we have bishop to f4 and now c captures
c captures and pawn to e6 so it's a it's
a very solid structure uh equal material
maxim does have a double death pawn but
maybe you can at some point maybe move
the king put the rooks on the g file
have some sort of an attack and also the
d4 pawn is a backward spawn so maksim uh
at some point if he piles up on it it
will be very very hard to
defend it and let's not forget uh it's
armageddon so it's magnus who needs to
push for a win here in order to win the
match so bishop g5 uh kicks away the
rook from
the the d file uh rook d the c8 and now
queen to e3 now with ideas of bishop h6
or maybe even bishop to f6 with knight
to e7 and now magnus goes for this
bishop trade bishop to f6 bishop to h6
is a bit more precise as it prevents h6
and h6 is a
very nice resource for maxime as it
prevents queen to g5 so this is what
maxine plays we have h6 queen to f4 now
preparing queen g3 and checkmate if
maxim allows it of course knight to
not that sorry about that knight to g6
and now queen to g3 uh we have king to
h7 getting the king away from the from
the g file and now magnus plays pawn to
d5 and this is just a wonderful move
it's a question whether to play it right
away or to first to maybe start push the
h pawn because you can maybe always play
this but it's armageddon you don't have
all the time in the world and maxime has
very little time on the clock so maxine
magnus doesn't want to let maxine think
and what this move does is it frees up
the d4 square for the knight uh but also
what it does is it it frees up the
entire fourth rank so you can make a
rook lift rook to b4 and bring the rook
rook into the attack uh e captures on d4
uh d5 and now you could play an id for
you could play knight h4 but magnus goes
for the immediate rook to b4 preparing
this rook lift uh because of course if
the knight captures then queen g7 will
be checkmate uh but the maxim stops at
rook the c4 and now magnus trades rook
captures b captures of course not the
capture so you don't want to hang your
queen and now pawn to e6 this is what
magnus found
when he played that d5 move attacking
the queen and the rook and now if this
was uh
i believe anyone
except maxine we would see queen c8 just
defending the rook and the game
continues maybe bishop captures in g7 uh
maybe king captures or maybe even better
f4 first we challenge the queen forcing
the queen to uh to the light square
diagonal and after queen g4 king
captures on g7 now making the capture on
f7 or pushing the pawn impossible as the
queen on g4 would hang but here maxine
just captures the pawn he says uh you
you can have the rook i'm maxine bashola
grav i always give up the rook uh so
okay queen captures and b8 magnus takes
it it is the strongest move bishop
captures an f6 and now rook to e1
attacking the queen queen to d7 and now
queen to b6 so it's not easy for magnus
to play this especially since he's the
one who needs to push this for a win uh
but maxine just can't stop himself he
has the black pieces in armageddon and
and he's playing for a win it's just the
the kind of player maxine is he now has
two connected past pawns and he is ready
to push them uh so king to g7 first uh
we have g3 creating a little bit of
breeding room for the king here and now
we have pawn to f4 uh here d4 is
incredibly strong if you can get this d4
and d3 in
your position just becomes much much
better but the maxim is incredibly low
on time here so he plays f4 first uh he
uh realized that there is a possibility
of uh of a peace sacrifice that would
allow uh him to get a perpetual check
and force force a draw uh so here queen
to c5 now magnus says all right you
didn't want to push d4 you're not
pushing it now because then the c4 pawn
hangs uh and here we have f captures on
g3 with this move maxine frees up the f4
square for the knight uh queen to f4 f5
still allows the maxim to push a little
bit harder for example king g2 h4 h5 h4
and so on uh but okay if captures on g3
maxim knows what he's doing h captures
and now comes the move uh knight to f4
uh if he didn't go for this he could
just push the pawn uh it will be nicely
defended on c3 but now if magnus
actually captures the pawn then queen g4
check and you will pick up the knight
king f1 let's see queen captures on f3
and you have all of these light squares
that you can use to
check to the white king and it will be
very very hard or rather impossible to
get out of all the checks uh but instead
we have queen to e3 magnus of course
doesn't capture the knight and now we
have knight to d3 by not capturing the
knight and allowing this perpetual
magnus has to go into a worse position
now comes knight to d3
rook to b1 and now we have queen to e6
offering a queen trade and this is again
you have to play d4 and depending on
where the queen goes pushed upon the c3
and so on before offering the queen
trade but here maxine trades the queen
right away rook to b7 and now uh queen
captures an e3 we have f captures and
pawn to c3 and now okay you are a little
bit better here but now uh
you you're playing an end game against
magnus and you are very very low on time
so that's never a sure thing so here
rook to c7 magnus absolutely has to
prevent this pawn from reaching c2 if it
reaches c2 c1 is covered so that's game
over knight to be for now guarding the
c2 pawn uh c2 square also attacking the
a2 pawn but now magnus has time to
activate his pieces uh or rather uh
the king and he should play king to f2
but he plays knight to e1 and this is
now uh a problem because it allows
maxime this beautiful tactic bishop to
e5 and okay you're attacking the rook
you're attacking the g3 pawn magnus just
moves the rook but now the problem is
because the knight is an e1 bishop
captures on g3 comes with an attack on
the knight and magnus does not have time
to capture the c3 pawn so king f1 he has
to waste the move and now comes the
bishop capture sunny one again knight
captures on a2 also always an option
bishop captures king captures and now
knight captures on a2 defending the pawn
here right now uh magnus is up the
exchange but maxine is up four pawns
which is which is quite a lot so here
king to d1 pawn to a3 we have rook to b8
and uh pawn to h5 now this pawn starts
marching forward as well king to c2 we
have pawn to h4 and rook to b1 so the
knight is now cut off from the game
and the king to b3 will win the knight
but again maxine has all of these extra
pawns
uh so king f6 we have king to b3 and now
uh here comes the magic moment maxim
should play
something like king to e5 or king to g5
just bring the king closer pick up this
pawn or even play c2 this is pretty much
a forced draw let's say king captures on
c2 because we are threatening to capture
the rook and also to promote so king
captures now we
gain some time because our knight
remains in the game and now after he
goes after this a king e4 king captures
an a2 and now you have plenty of pawns
and you will get a draw here there's
nothing that white can do to prevent you
from getting the king here and pushing
this pawn king captures an a3 just king
f2 and white will have to resort to uh
perpetual checks here
however maxine played knight to b4 and
it's the weirdest move uh ever uh but
it's not it's you know easily
dismissible as a blender it is a blender
but no one realizes it's a blender
except for magnus magnus captures the
knife right away and he says now you're
not uh you're not getting a draw now i'm
just going to beat you and here we have
ponte a2 and this is the problem this is
the position that uh obviously neither
of them thought possible
because uh there are winning moves here
and there of course are uh
drawing moves here and there of course
are losing moves here so feel free to
pause the video and try to figure out
the moves that are winning here for
white while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
because it's not easy
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show rook to a1 leaving the
rook on b1 rook to c1 and rook to d1 are
not good moves if you do this you are
not winning the game as white or even
rook to e1 however rook to f1 rook to g1
and rook to h1 are winning for white so
that's pretty incredible
now in the game magnus played rook to a1
and of course we're going to show what
happens here but just to give an example
you could play
between the three we're gonna go to f1
as this one comes with check so it makes
sense and also there's a pawn on f7 uh
so let's explore this what happens okay
king g5 of course black wants to get the
king here and push this pawn we're gonna
play king b3 king the g4 and now king
captures on a2 this pawn is a priority
h3 we're gonna play rook captures on f7
and now after king to g3 king to b3 pawn
to h2 now we cover the queening square
rook to h7 king to g2 and now king
captures on c3 and now after h1 queen
we're gonna capture the queen king
captures and now finally king to d4 we
win the game uh by but only by a temple
king g2 uh king captures on d5 and now
if the black king was already here he
could just gobble up the pawn but he
he's gonna play king of three now we
push e4 our pass pawn is protected and
we are winning this game so that's uh
one way to do it however magnus played
rook to a1 and now the position is no
longer winning
because here maxine plays c2 and now the
situation is much much different we have
king to c3 now comes pawn to h3 here we
have king captures on c2 and here uh
incredible as it is maxine played king
the g5 and after king to d3 he was in
this position on move 54 that maksim
vashila grav resigned the game uh but he
also lost on time basically when he
resigned uh he had zero zero zero he i
guess he saw that he was on a few
seconds on the clock and then he just
decided to resign uh as uh there now
really is nothing more you can do here
and maksim knows that this is uh winning
uh for magnus however there was instead
of king the king the f5 uh king instead
of king
g5 that was played in the game king to
f5 is a draw incredible but end games
are just spectacular in that in that way
uh so the
reason why this is so uh sorry not to
this king of five uh
uh yeah this can get five uh the reason
is after king to d3 here now we're gonna
play ponte h2 that's the that's the good
stuff and now after let's say king to d4
going after the pawn we're gonna play f6
after king captures on d5 we're gonna
play king to g4 after king to e4 we're
gonna play ponte f5 with check king back
to d4 now king to f3 uh notice that
white can never capture the pawn because
black will just queen the h pawn king to
d3 now we're gonna play f4 we get rid of
a white's pass pawn uh pawn captures
here king captures king e2 and now king
the g3 and there is no way there is no
good way to prevent king to g2 if king
to e3 king to g2 and now uh how are you
stopping rook to h1 you have to resort
to rook captures on a2 with check and
after kng 1 rook a1 checking g2 and
you're going to have to repeat otherwise
black will just get a queen into the
game so this is how you draw the problem
is after king to g5 this is a
tempo not well spent the problem is
after king to d3 the moment when maxim
resigned the game
you don't have a good continuation if
you just play king to f5 we have the
exact same position like we did uh in
the previous line only it's white to
move black lost the tempo and now it's
completely winning rook capture 72 and
your king is too far behind king g4
we're going to play rook to f2 now and
after king g3 we gobble up the f7 pawn
king g2 rook h7 and now again after h2
just king d4 and we have a similar
position to the one that we've already
discussed h1 queen we're going to
capture captures characters and now you
are too too far behind to stop the past
pawn from queening and winning
and the other thing if you don't want to
repeat king to f5 because you've already
played king to g5 uh you could continue
king g4 but now we don't go after the d
pawn now we played the spectacular king
to e2 this is uh of course in with so
little time on the clock uh not easy to
find but the point is after king to g3
there's rook to g1 and now you either
force the black king back and then of
course the white is completely winning
or he goes forward and then you play
king f2 completely locking the king in
and now black has no other moves other
than pushing the pawns and once all the
pawns have been pushed let's say rook to
a1 we're going to play d4 e captures on
d4 f4 we have to waste all the moves we
can even capture on a2 and now after
king h1 we're going to play d5 f3 let's
say king to g3 and now we just checked
mate to the black king pawn to f2 rook
to a1 with check f1 probably a queen and
rook captures on f1 will be checkmate so
that's uh how incredible uh end games
are and why you should always study the
end game before you know even even
having breakfast
uh yeah after king to d3 uh maxine
resigned and he also lost on time and
magnus carlsen wins the game incredibly
incredibly complicated uh which is a
shame for maxine he was winning in
classical had two clear winning
opportunities but if you've seen the
previous video you know how they were
incredibly difficult to spot uh and here
again maxine was much better but when it
was crucial to start pushing those pawns
uh he he hesitated and that was enough
he gave magnet if he just before trading
queens for example played those d4 and
c3 moves uh then his pawns would be too
far ahead and magnus would there would
be nothing else to do but here he gave
magnus a slightly worse end game to play
and but with more time on the clock and
there was enough for magnus to play this
uh so sorry for a bit of a longer video
on an armageddon game uh but it's such a
complicated endgame that even by showing
only a few lines we've uh you know
explored quite a lot uh so yeah here are
the standings as i know you guys really
enjoy those after uh the penultimate
round uh magnus carlsen leading the
tournament with 15 points we have
shakhtar madara with 14 and a half in
second vishwanathan anand in 13 uh in
third place with 13 and maxine marshall
are in fourth place with 12 and a half
and i think only four of them are
contending for first place as a winning
classical gives you three points so i
believe even maybe in some scenario
maxim can win uh but uh you know
not not so sure however uh anand mahmoud
and the magnus can still uh uh all three
of them are are sure that they can they
can win it then we have wesley so and
anisha in 11 uh wrestling to paula
though with eight and a half iron 38 and
a half one how six and a half and ten
more job of six and a half so hope you
enjoyed the standings as well we see
we'll see what the final round brings uh
and uh of course i would like to thank
charles huff nagarjuna ponogoti team
solo adrian martinez and benjamin
bogwell for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing the coverage of this
magnificent tournament until it finishes
uh so see you soon and uh you know hope
you have uh uh an excellent rest of your
day and uh it's really a shame that uh
another groomfield such uh you know
played with such elegance uh did not
result in more uh than a drawing
classical and a loss in armageddon
but yeah that's just see you soon